Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlav, hallo und es ist Freitag der zweiundzwanzigste Januar.
Zwanzig, einundzwanzig und das heißt Corona Wickly ist wieder angesagt und ja das natürlich mit mir und mit Pavel Meier, hallo Pavel.
Ja, eine Woche ist vergangene Woche, die wir in der letzten Sendung abgeschlossen haben, so ein bisschen mit etwas Unklarheit darüber, wie sich denn jetzt alles so entwickeln kann,
stellt sich raus, es hat eine Entwicklung gegeben, das werden wir dann auch gleich aktuell besprechen.
Ich dachte mir nur vielleicht ist es ganz angemessen heute nochmal mit etwas Feedback anzufangen, dass wir das gleich vom Tisch haben und gar nicht erst vergessen wieder einzubringen.
Ähm ja und Feedback gab's vor allem, weil wir nein, du hast dich verrechnet und ich hab's nicht gemerkt.
Ja, so, so sieht das aus, weil äh du hast ja mal, wir haben ja darüber nachgedacht, was äh was denn Deutschland so der Impfstoff kostet und ob denn dann das nun nennenswerte Kosten sind.
Ja und dann hast du einfach mal die äh hundertsechzig Millionen Dosen, die wir da irgendwie kaufen müssen, hochgerechnet auf hundertsechzig Millionen Euro.
Und da haben wir dann wieder mal einen Faktor zehn Fehler, weil.
Bei so zehn bis zwölf Euro pro Dosis, die das wahrscheinlich kostet, kommen wir jetzt so billig dann doch nicht davon. So.
Ja. Äh okay gut ähm ja ähm ja.
Okay, äh ja, also eins Komma sechs Milliarden Jahr ist aber äh ich sag mal.
Genau eine Größenordnung, äh aber es äh immer noch äh ich sage mal eins bis zwei Größenordnungen unter dem, was uns das Ganze sonst kostet. Also insofern, ja, ist ein peinlicher Fehler, für den ich mich entschuldigen möchte, aber
ändert jetzt nichts am Sachverhalt, dass äh dass das Ganze bei uns nicht wirklich eine große Delle äh in die in die Finanzen macht,
also das äh ja.
Nee, also zumal, ich meine, das ist ja auch eine reine Rechnung gewesen auf Basis, was kostet jetzt der Einkauf
dieses Impfstoff und tatsächlich ist ja an der Verabreichung einer Impfung hängt ja noch sehr viel mehr dran. Die,
der Transport, die Lagerung, die Organisation, extrem hohe Personalkosten für die Impfzentren und die ganze Logistik et cetera PP. Die Rechnung kann ich natürlich jetzt nicht aufmachen, weil diese Kosten sind äh so nicht bekannt.
Aber äh die hängen da natürlich noch mit dran, was ich damit sagen möchte, ist der Preis des Impfstoff selber, ist.
Ein Teil, aber bei Leibe nicht unbedingt äh der größte Teil und selbst wenn es so wäre.
Ist es halt auch alles noch zu stemmen. Also das daran hängt es jetzt nicht, ne? Das Ganze hatten wir ja im Kontext dessen, debattiert dieses Aufrufs nach Sirokowit und äh,
ob denn nun sozusagen diese Impfstoffe in irgendeiner Form freigegeben werden sollten et cetera, da gab's dann auch in den Kommentaren nochmal so die ein oder andere Rückmeldung.
Ich würde grundsätzlich noch auf der Position bleiben.
Dass ich das nicht in der aktuellen Situation einerseits nicht als notwendig erachte, also nicht um diese konkrete Krise jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt in irgendeiner Form zu bekämpfen und darüber hinaus auch
Na ja, äh da so ein bisschen meine Bedenken habe, ob's äh das denn nun so wirklich bringen wird zu dieser
immer wieder in den Raum gestellte Vorwurf der Bereicherung, was ich irgendwie in dem Moment
wirklich finde sehr schwieriges schwierigen Begriff halte, ja? Man würde sich ja an der Krise bereichern und das das wäre ja jetzt in irgendeiner Form unangemessen
Naja, weiß ich nicht, müssten dann irgendwie die FFP zwei Masken auch alle äh äh kostenlos geliefert werden. So bereichern sich Leute da auch an der Krise, also am Ende ist es ja einfach Teil unseres normalen
Wirtschaftslebens und wenn das jetzt generell im medizinischen Bereichen auch gelten würde, dann müsste man das ja eigentlich auch auf alle Medikamenten äh so machen.
Gibt natürlich auch da Bereiche, wo es vielleicht nicht so gut läuft und Medikamente zu teuer sind, aber das ist jetzt auch mal eine komplett andere Debatte, die wir jetzt hier so in der Form auch nicht unbedingt führen müssen.
Also ich werde dafür, dass man halt so ein bisschen dann die übermäßigen Gewinne der Krisengewinnler dann im Nachhinein einfach ein bisschen abschöpft, ja. Äh.
Das wäre meiner Meinung nach die vernünftigste Lösung.
Ja, dafür gibt's Steuern. Also wenn jemand viel Geld verdient, so, dann äh nimmt man dann halt Steuern und dann verdient der Staat halt auch daran wieder sein Geld zurück. So funktioniert das ja eigentlich immer.
Dann hat mir dieses schöne Segment mit äh ähm der Vorgehensweise in Niedersachsen und wie sich's jetzt abzeichnet, wohl auch noch anderen Bundesländern, äh wo die Benachrichtigungen mit äh über das Einwohnermeldeverzeichnis äh.
Irgendwie keine keine keine leicht zu lösende Aufgabe ist und hier teilweise Postdienste ähm herangezogen werden, die dann eben um ihren.
Ja, die dann sozusagen ja nicht diese Altersinformation haben und dort äh Namen.
Auf einmal als Anhaltspunkt nehmen, wie alt denn eine Person wäre.
Anhand des Vornamens.
Anhand des Vornamens, ja? Also wenn man jetzt sozusagen einen typischen Vornamen hat, wie man ihn vielleicht.
Das hast du gesagt.
Na ja, aber so es gibt ja vorne, also es gibt ja Vornamen, denen man in gewisser Hinsicht ähm unterstellt, dass sie äh heutzutage eher ältere Leute tragen würden und die dann eben, weil das ja immer so ein, so ein, so ein,
der was gerade so Fashion ist.
Genau, mir, mir fiel halt deswegen auch Adolf ein, weil der halt sehr in Fashion und dann sehr out of Fashion. Äh äh war ja.
Gut, aber das hat nochmal andere Gründe. Auf jeden Fall äh habe ich äh einen Hinweis bekommen von ähm.
Einem Hörer aus Hamburg.
Wo tatsächlich auch ein Brief reingeflattert äh ist von der Bundesregierung mit einem Berechtigungsschein für sechs Schutzmasten mit hoher Schutzwirkung zur Abholung in einer Apotheke mit zwei Euro Eigenbeteiligung.
Für äh ja jemanden mit dem Namen Hans-Christian Albert.
Dass äh hat offensichtlich schon äh gereicht, hier äh eine entsprechende Bewilligung auszusprechen. Das Problem ist, äh, Hans-Christian Albert ist drei Jahre alt und hat jetzt nicht so unmittelbaren Bedarf.
Würde ich mal sagen, ne?
Und ich muss auch sagen, zwei Euro Eigenanteil, also ich habe jetzt gerade mal wieder ein größeres Paket FFP zwei Masken auf Amazon gekauft, da hat mich eine Maske eins fünfzig gekostet.
Ja, das ist so ungefähr. Ich habe jetzt auch wieder auch eine Bestellung aufgegeben. Ich habe nämlich gesehen, die die Dinger gibt's auch ab Werk in schwarz übrigens. Äh so, deswegen habe ich mir jetzt irgendwie ein paar weiße und ein paar schwarze bestellt. Ja.
Schicko. Schiko. Äh demnächst gibt's hier denn bestimmt auch noch mit bunten Aufdrucken. Ist noch einiges zu holen.
Ja, ich habe, ich habe gesehen im äh im Senat äh
und so machen die das jetzt teilweise so, dass sie halt äh FFP zwei unten drunter und dann oben drüber sagen noch die designte Alltagsmaske, das ist so ein bisschen jetzt die die
einen Trend äh sage ich mal. Der Trend geht zur doppelten Maskierung.
Ja, stimmt, das war jetzt auch der Style bei der enorm in Auguration, da hatten sie auch alle so äh für B zwei Masken und dadrüber dann halt noch ein bisschen Deko.
Wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht so 'ne schlechte Idee, weil dann kann man nämlich auch einfach irgend so ein beliebigen hübschen Stoff nehmen der einfach nur zur Verkleidung dient und das Fashion Statement macht und dadrunter kann man dann eben schön äh austauschen die.
Maske, die ich mir auch selber genäht hatte, äh Anu Dame, dazu mals im März
äh zwanzig zwanzig äh war dann auch so diese Hongkong Maske. Dieser Hongkong äh Schnitt, so hieß das
ähm wo man dann aber noch so ein Fleece einziehen kann, was es hier so nicht zu kaufen gibt, aber äh wo in Hock ganz
gängig war, dass man dann so allgemeine Filterfließer hatte, die man einfach in die Stoffmaske selber reinmacht, dann kann man das Fleece wegschmeißen, austauschen und die Maske einfach normal waschen. Ja und dann.
War das auch so das Ding, aber am Ende muss ich sagen, habe ich dann äh ja erstmal mit den ganzen normalen.
Äh Mundnasenschutzdingern, den OP-Masten besser gelebt, hatten wir ja auch drüber gesprochen und mittlerweile
mache ich einfach auch nur noch FP zwei und fertig. Zur FLP zwei Masken habe ich dann auch im hinteren Teil der Sendung nochmal ein extra Segment
Jetzt wollte ich erstmal nochmal ein bisschen weitermachen mit dem Feedback, bevor wir zu den Zahlen kommen, ein weiteres Feedback gab's dann noch, zu einer Aussage.
Zu den Impfstofftypen von Leere Borgu und da zitiere ich mal wortwörtlich. Ähm und zwar die
klassischen Vektorimpfstoffe, die Pavel erwähnt,
äh gibt es so nicht. Rekombinant äh war Revector Wexzenes sind genauso wie MRNA-Magstine, eine neue Technologie. Das erste und einzige mir bekannte bisher zugelassene virale Viktor Wagzin ist
RVSVC Boff äh gegen Ebola zugelassen zwanzig neunzehn von der IMA und FDA,
Ich denke, Pavel malte die klassischen Live-Attenurated Hole in Activate-Impfstoffe. Astra Sinnika äh Ochsford gehört,
da aber nicht dazu. Tim meinte, dass ACD zwölf zweiundzwanzig, also das ist dieser Impfstoff von äh aus Oxford.
Astra Senika, äh auch ein Lipidnano-Partikel sei, da Virus ist in dem Fall nicht ganz korrekt, wenn der verwendete Viktor.
Gehört zu den Adenovi äh Viren, wie auch Sputnik äh und äh Johnson and Johnson. Welche zu den Non-Entwellopt Viren gehören?
Und damit zu den nackten Viren ohne Doppel-Lipidschicht. Bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sicher, dass ich das gesagt hätte. Ich wundere mich jetzt so ein bisschen, äh ist mir vielleicht so rausgerutscht, weil ich glaube, also ich habe da jetzt
nicht so klare Erkenntnisse äh was diesen AZD zwölf zweiundzwanzig betrifft, aber kann sein, dass mir das so rausgerutscht ist
weiter noch im Text trotz der Neuheit der Technologie habe ich keine Bedenken zu MRNA wie Kombinanten Viral Viktor Waxin nach erfolgreich durchlaufender Phase drei Studie. Trotzdem fände ich wie Tim interessant, auf welche Studien.
Pavels hier bezieht im Zusammenhang mit sytotoxischen Wirkungen von äh LNPs, also den
Liquid Nano Partikeln. Ich weiß nicht, hat mir da keinen Link zu.
Wie gesagt, ich hab dann also mir sind da halt ein paar Slides über den Weg gelaufen, ich glaube ich hatte dir das auch geschickt, ich hab dem jetzt auch leider nicht weiter nachrecherchiert äh.
So ähm ja ähm vielleicht.
Können wir das zur nächsten Sendung äh nochmal dann dann aufklären ähm.
Ja, ich schaue, ich schaue nochmal in die Shownotes und zur Not tragen wir das die Shownotes äh dieser Sendung.
Ja gut und ähm ja mit dem und zum Thema irgendwie.
Klassisch und weckt impfstoff
Gut, da war mir das klassisch in dem Sinne rausgerutscht, dass sozusagen Vectoring mit Hilfe von Adenovieren
ist äh halt auf jeden Fall etwas, was man schon länger macht, also länger jedenfalls als ähm mit den Lipid-Nanopartikeln. So, das ist also eine eine
ja sage ich mal eine erprobtere äh Technologie so, aber ja ähm.
Ansonsten äh ähm ja in der Tat, also die klassischen Impfstoffe sind halt dann äh typischerweise entweder ja geschwächte äh Viren oder oder Virus äh.
Partikel, also entweder Lebende oder,
lebende Geschwächte oder Tote, Viren, das sind so die im Prinzip die klassischen Impfstoffe und dann das mit dem Vectoring ist halt, wenn man dann irgendwie entweder über einen Virus,
über einen Adenovirus üblicherweise oder halt über Lipidnanopartikel dann äh Erbgut in die Zelle einschleust. So.
Na gut, das können wir ähm,
vielleicht nochmal klären, denn wie es gerade so hip ist, äh, planen wir mal eine kleine Feedback-Runde zu machen, dass wir da nicht immer diese schwierigen Rückkanal haben
solltet ihr also auch schon dem aktuellen Hype um Clubhaus verfallen äh sein, dann könnt ihr am Montag um einundzwanzig Uhr dann mit uns äh quatschen
und.
Solltet ihr da noch nicht auf der Plattform sein oder nicht, ist auch egal. Wir versuchen einfach nur mit den Leuten, die wir da äh mühelos erreichen können, mal ins Gespräch zu kommen und noch ein paar Experten äh dazu zu holen, die ja
das alles noch teilweise ein bisschen besser drauf haben im Detail als wir und vielleicht ähm könnte das was äh geben,
So, damit sind wir dann aber zu unserem traditionellen Hauptsegment äh vorgestoßen
und wollen nochmal schauen, was denn die Zahlenlawine des RKI so für interessante Erkenntnisse für uns hat. Letztes Mal, habe ich ja schon erwähnt.
Punkt angekommen, wo es irgendwie so oder so laufen könnte und sich nichts wirklich unmittelbar abgezeichnet hat
weil wir das auch schon vorher gesehen haben, dass wir schon mal an solchen Punkten waren, uns dann mal nach oben, mal nach unten gingen. Wie sieht's denn jetzt aus.
Ja, jetzt sieht es ja, kann sagen durchaus positiv aus,
also die Zahlen haben jetzt gerade einen deutlichen Trend nach unten so bei den,
ja sieben Tage Schnitt äh sind wir jetzt ziemlich genau äh da, äh wo wir am zweiten elften waren, als wir den Lokdown Light
als wir angefangen haben mit dieser ewigen Logdown Phase. So und.
Ja wenn das jetzt so weiter.
Laufen sollte in der Geschwindigkeit ja ähm
Na ja, wenn wir in ein bis zwei Monate noch durchhalten äh äh könnten
dann ja könnte man so irgendwann in ein bis zwei Monaten tatsächlich vorsichtig äh an die ersten Öffnungen äh denken
aber ja man wird sehen, wir wissen ja üblicherweise.
Verpuffen ja Maßnahmen nach einer Weile, aber was sich jetzt zeigt, ist okay, wenn man halt einen
relativ harten Logdown macht, dann funktioniert der auch. So. Im Gegensatz zu dem, was wir so vorher hatten, was nur so halb funktioniert hat,
Ja ähm also.
Das zweite Positive ist, dass sich auch die Zahl der Toten jetzt stabilisiert hat, beziehungsweise äh sogar jetzt der sieben Tages äh Schnitt auch.
Erstmals seit langem gesunken ist so und wenn wir jetzt dann einen Blick.
Die Testzahlen werfen, dann bestätigt sich da auch der Abwärtstrend, weil was man nämlich auch immer ganz gut an den Testzahlen,
sehen kann, so an der letztlich an der Positivitätsrate, wie viel Prozent positiven Anteil.
Ähm haben wir äh eigentlich bei den Tests und äh wenn der zurückgeht.
Und die Zahl der Tests äh sagen nicht gleichzeitig äh extrem ausgeweitet wurde, dann kann man davon ausgehen,
dass die Zahlen, dass die tatsächlich zurückgegangen sind, beziehungsweise die nicht nur die Zahlen zurückgegangen sind, sondern auch die äh reale Infektionsausbreitung.
Also die Tests sind um ungefähr fünf Komma zwo fünf Prozent zurückgegangen. Die Anzahl der Tests.
Und die positiven Quote lag jetzt in, also wir beziehen uns jetzt auf die KW zwei einundzwanzig äh bei zehn Komma fünf Prozent.
Und es war in der Woche davor zwölf Komma sieben acht Prozent und das ist dann halt auch mal ein weiterer
Rückgang dieser positiven Quote. Wir hatten ja schon in der letzten Woche einen Rückgang letzte Woche um zwanzig Prozent und jetzt um siebzehn Komma acht Prozent und das ist zumindest schon mal ein Trend.
Das ist schon mal ein deutlicher Trend, zumal wir ja bei äh zwischen.
Zeitlich ja bei sechzehn äh Komma null sieben Prozent waren in der in der Spitze in der äh KW dreiundfünfzig.
Also ja, man kann sagen, der Lokdown zeigt Wirkung gerade, das kann man.
So festhalten und äh ja wenn wir da noch, ich sage mal, ein, zwei, eher zwei als ein Monat.
Durchhalten dann ja kommen wir auch irgendwohin.
Tja, dann kommen wir in den März, da kommen wir in Mitte März. Da muss ich doch jetzt glatt mal gucken, wie sich das eigentlich, wann ist denn Ostern eigentlich? Ostern ist Ende März.
Oh je.
Da wollen ja wieder alle Urlaub machen. Ich würd's ja allen gönnen.
Ja, also ich befürchte ja eher.
Dass dann plötzlich also ist die Lockerungsdiskussion die gehen ja jetzt jetzt schon los dass wir auch tendenziell eher fast zu früh lockern
werden, wobei.
Ich das Gefühl habe, dass noch die äh jenigen, also die, ich sage mal, die harten Lokdown-Befürworter gerade noch,
in der Mehrheit sind in der Bundesregierung und im Moment,
glaube ich, dass noch das ist aber man merkt schon, wie halt einzelne Länder anfangen jetzt gerade schon auszuscheren und unbedingt wieder die Schulen aufmachen wollen und äh so weiter.
Auch was jetzt den R Wert angeht.
Ist es so bundesweit ja liegen wir jetzt bei knapp null Komma neun.
Also etwas unter null Komma neun für den sieben Tage R-Wert null Komma acht acht wäre das das ist.
Schon mal was, also das heißt, dass man so sagen von Woche zu Woche zwanzig Prozent weniger hat, das spürt man schon als Rückgang.
Ist aber ja es ging schon mal besser.
So, also wir waren waren schon mal im ersten Lokdown ein bisschen besser, aber ansonsten.
Äh sehen die Zahlen bisschen besser aus, als sich's erwartet äh hatte. So, kann man sagen, also ich finde es erfreulich, wie die Zahlen sich in der letzten Woche entwickelt haben.
Ja, aber eine Woche reicht nicht, ne? Wenn ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen mir einfach mal die Grafik äh äh schnappe und das mal so ein bisschen vergleiche, da ist ja gesagt, ein oder zwei Monate, ne? Also
wenn man jetzt mal so die aktuelle Dreijektorie so ein bisschen in die Zukunft verlängern, würde ich mal meinen würde es jetzt so bleiben
Ja, würde, würde vielleicht unter Umständen, ne, muss man halt immer so sehen, dann wären wir vielleicht in einem Monat.
So in diesem Bereich, dieser fünfziger äh Institanz, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Mhm.
Wir erinnern uns, das ist so äh der Schwellwert gewesen, wo alle langsam anfingen, bisschen auszuticken, wo dann auf einmal Berlin äh der böse verseuchte Ort war,
Ja, Berlin, was erlaube, Berlin. Äh kurz danach äh ging's irgendwie allen an den Kragen und dann hat sich das auch wieder schnell verflüchtigt. Das ist jetzt auch noch nicht ausreichend
nur dann eben über diese vier Wochen hinaus noch ein bisschen Anstrengung zu machen, sagen wir mal nochmal so zwei Wochen, also zumindest so sechs Wochen durchhalten. Das könnte uns dann tatsächlich in diesen Bereich der fünfundzwanziger Institzen bringen,
zumindest mal sagen kann.
Man hat nicht so dieses Gefühl in Zombielands zu leben, wo wie jeder fünfzigste, der auf der Straße einem begegnet, potenziell gerade mit einem aktiven Virus im Maul durch die Gegend läuft.
Dass wir so die Perspektive, also Mitte Februar Ende Februar und das deckt sich ja eigentlich auch so ein bisschen mit unseren Erwartungen, die wir hier schon.
Zu Beginn des Lokdownlights oder dann auch im Laufe des Dezembers geäußert haben.
Ja
Ja, ansonsten, ich meine Deutschland jetzt reale Institutionen jetzt hundertdreiundvierzig äh im Moment die.
Vom RKI ausgewiesene, weil er immer Fälle ignoriert werden eher bei hundertdreißig, so.
Ungefähr und ja bei den bei den Bundesländern Bremen.
Mit vierundachtzig steht am besten da und äh Brandenburg und Sachsen-Anhalt und Sachsen und.
Thüringen sind noch so in den zweihundertfünfziger Regionen unterwegs, also ja zweihundert.
Vierundvierzig bis zweihundertachtzig in dem Bereich so und dann
kommt ist so die die größte Gruppe der der Bundesländer so von Bayern, Berlin, Hessen, NRW, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, Bavy, ja, Saarland, Rheinland-Pfalz und Hamburg.
Die liegen so alle immer noch über hundert ja ähm zwischen hundert und hundertfünfzig.
So, also wir haben sagen jetzt einmal so eine eine Flotte immer noch von vier Bundesländern, die noch richtig hoch sind.
Und ja.
Aber muss man auch dazu sagen, alle Bundesländer haben signifikante signifikant sinkende Zahlen, also es
ist einfach äh besonders das stark betroffene Sachsen hat eine Menge äh umdrehen können, auch Thüringen ist ganz gut unterwegs, also da ist wirklich ein Turnaround auch erreicht worden und äh da wo die Rückgänge geringer sind, da ist halt auch unhin nicht so viel los wie Schleswig-Holstein oder Bremen und
das sieht soweit schon mal ganz gut aus. Wenn das jetzt mindestens zwei Wochen so bleibt, so, dann.
Dann werde ich auch langsam optimistisch, dass dass ich äh äh auch an den Sterbezahlen nennenswert was ändern kann.
Ja? Weil die gehen ja äh wie gesagt schon glücklicherweise äh auch äh langsam leicht nach unten. Ähm.
Ja, aber auf hohem Niveau.
Auf ja auf nach wie vor viel zu hohem Niveau. Also wir sind immer noch ja.
Bei achthundert im Wochenschnitt sind wir jetzt pro Tag. So, Trote, das ist natürlich immer noch viel, viel, viel zu hoch.
Ja
Dann wird natürlich jetzt aber demnächst jetzt wieder die Schuldebatte kommen, ne? Also ich habe jetzt den Überblick über die Bundesländer nicht. Ähm in.
Berlin ist es so, die Schulen harten jetzt diese Woche noch zu, die werden auch die nächste Woche noch zu haben und dann hatten wir glaube ich schon mal, dann wird so diese diese Situation kommen, dass Winterferien anstehen. Ich.
Muss man erstmal kurz nochmal den Schulferienplan von Deutschland äh holen, wie weit das eigentlich auseinander äh geht bei diesen Winterferien, die existieren ja doch glaube ich nicht äh überall so, das ist so eine typische Geschichte in Berlin und Bayern.
Ähm Entschuldigung, äh Berlin und Brandenburg gibt's diese Winterferien in anderen Ländern, noch in Sachsen und der Rest hat sowas nicht bis auf Thüringen, die.
Da ist das jetzt nächste Woche und dann hat Mecklenburg-Vorpommern noch so einen Zwei-Wochen-Block in zwei Wochen.
Verzichtet auf sowas komplett, da sind dann halt wahrscheinlich glaube ich die Weihnachtsferien länger und.
Die Osterferien sind dann teilweise drei Wochen und.
Genau, also es ist ein bisschen anders verteilt. Also ähm das heißt, es gibt relativ viel Öffnungspotential
und äh ich wäre schon froh, wenn jetzt zumindest Berlin noch durchhält und noch die Winterferien noch mit dranhängt, also so zwei Wochen Schulen zu, fände ich es schon mal ganz gut. Dann könnt ihr das auch mit dem Digital und so noch ein bisschen lernen. Also,
Das wäre vielleicht gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ja, wahrscheinlich sagen, machen offene Schulen äh genau den Unterschied aus zwischen.
Zahlen gehen runter und zahlen bleiben gleich so in der momentanen Sit.
Ja. Schulen sind jetzt nicht der einzige Infektionstreiber oder vielleicht auch nicht der Hauptinfektionstreiber äh aber bei der bei der.
Debatte immer so, was sind denn jetzt die Infektionstreiber ähm.
Sind wir in der Situation, dass wir eigentlich alle.
Potenziellen Infektionstreiber so weit wie möglich angehen müssen. Lange es zu sagen hier ja wir,
halten dies auf oder jenes auf oder das auf, weil es doch nur geringfügig zur Infektion äh beiträgt. Wir brauchen auch jedes geringfügig ähm so müssen wir halt reduzieren,
im Moment, weil in der Summe, wir haben halt nicht viel Spielraum, mit 'n mit 'nem R.
Zwischen null Komma acht und null Komma neun eher eigentlich bei null Komma neun.
Bundesweit ja da ist ja da ist im Moment kein Öffnungspotential.
Zumal wir ja jetzt auch Christian Drosten nicht müde wird zu betonen, wir immer noch das Problem haben, dass eben die neue äh UK Virusvariante sich hier breit machen äh könnte, um das wahrscheinlich auch tun wird
da haben wir ja auch schon drüber geredet, dass gerade in Großbritannien das dann eben auch in den Schulen dazu geführt hat, dass die Zahlen nach oben gingen, ja? Also nicht die Schulen waren alleine Schuld, sondern.
Das war halt einfach.
Die Mutante war da und umso mehr Orte, sie hatte äh sich zu verbreiten, hat sie natürlich ihren Verbreitungsvorteil dann auch ausgenutzt, also man muss die Gesamtinfektionszahl einfach nennenswert runterkriegen, damit auch diese Variante dann kein Problem mehr ist.
Aber in einem Zustand wie jetzt, wo die wo einfach die die Institzen noch
Noch zu hoch sind, wo eigentlich immer noch sehr viel Virusaktivität da ist. Jetzt noch eine Steigerung, so ein Push durch eine sich leichter verbreitende Virusart zu bekommen
Würde dann eben einfach unsere aktuellen Erfolge komplett dicht machen. Also wäre jetzt der in Deutschland dominante Virus
diese Variante aus UK, was derzeit sicherlich noch nicht der Fall ist, sondern hier und da, ne. Aber wäre es so, dann hätten wir mit Sicherheit keinen eher
unter eins.
Das äh ja wobei man auch.
Ähm immer wieder betonen muss, das Reduzieren von Kontakten ähm reduziert auch die Ausbreitung der neuen Virusvarianten
Also die sind die durchtunneln jetzt auch nicht auf magische Weise Wände und äh Wabern jetzt nicht so durch die durch die Stadt und äh ja es braucht halt mehr und was ich
auch jetzt gelesen habe ist, dass die Zahl der Kontakte aber nach Verkehrsbewegungsmustern hier Google und andere Dienste.
Ist es wohl so, dass jetzt zwischenzeitlich tatsächlich die Zahl der Kontakte äh im neuen Jahr soweit reduziert worden ist, wie sie auch mal während der ersten.
Welle, wie er reduziert hat, so das ist. Äh also schon mal ganz
gut äh was soll man sagen? Aber die Frage ist, wie lange das anhält und äh beispielsweise der Straßenverkehr gestern ich,
neue eine neue Batterie fürs Motorrad brauchte, bin ich halt ein bisschen rumgefahren und die Stadt war voll so. Also das ist immer so ein bisschen mich dann auch einen Indikator.
Äh tagsüber äh ist äh richtig Aktivität in der Stadt. Weiß nicht, ob dir das auch aufgefallen ist.
Ich bewege mich ja äh kaum.
Durch die Gegend. Also ich habe abgesehen von meinen kurzen Spaziergängen im Block und äh im angrenzenden Park
Ich bin nicht aus dem Kilometer äh oder zwei Kilometer Radius um meine Wohnung heraus rumgekommen und bin eigentlich auch.
Mit dem Auto bestenfalls unterwegs, wenn ein Großeinkauf Supermarkt ansteht.
Ja, also ich bin ab und zu, so bin ich mit dem Motorrad
unterwegs und da ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass so vor ein, zwei Wochen teilweise wirklich die Straßen sehr leer waren, vor allem äh wenn's dann etwas später
wurde so, dass äh dann ganz nett, aber das scheint sich jetzt auch wieder langsam zu verändern. Also ich,
Würde denken, dass ja wir auch jetzt trotz der anhalten.
Den Lokdown-Regeln und sogar teilweise kleineren äh Verschärfungen hier und da ähm das,
die äh ähm ja, dass dass äh äh die.
Effektivität wahrscheinlich jetzt von Woche zu Woche abnehmen könnte, der Maßnahmen, dass die Leute wieder aktiver werden.
Also ich habe mir gerade mal hier die Mobility äh Reports angeschaut.
Es gibt ja diese Mobilitätstrends, ne, äh sowohl von Apple als auch von Google. Äh ich habe jetzt gerade die von Apple vor der Nase. Ich glaube, die unterscheiden sich nicht nennenswert.
Ist schon erstaunlich, also wir haben das jetzt hier richtig deute, tatsächlich seit.
Ja seit November äh abnehmende Mobilität.
Und das ist dann auch zu löst das hier zeitlich nicht so genau auf. Ich kann das jetzt hier grade nur so erahnen, also tatsächlich ist es dann um Weihnachten herum hat es so sein Tief erreicht.
Klar, ne? Also die Leute sind dann Weihnachten irgendwo und bleiben dann mal eine Woche da. Aber äh im ganzen Januar ist ja ist die Mobilität nicht nennenswert angestiegen,
Also wir haben tatsächlich gerade ein Mobilitätsniveau wie na ja ungefähr ein.
Zwei Wochen, nachdem so die tiefste Phase im ersten Doktor erreicht war. Also immer noch minus dreißig äh Prozent, was das Autofahren betrifft
ungefähr minus fünfzig Prozent, was so ähm Gen und ÖPNV.
Also ist schon ist schon weniger. Vielleicht sind wir auch schon nix mehr gewohnt, wenn wenn wir irgendwie andere Menschen sehen, dann kommt uns das gleich nach viel vor.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Äh
Ja, wenn vor einem noch andere Fahrzeuge an der roten Ampel stehen, dann empfindet man es schon äh reizvoll.
Ja
Also ist ein bisschen schwierig hier Empfehlungen zu geben, die Maßnahmen, die jetzt nochmal äh nachbeschlossen wurden, beziehen sich ja im Wesentlichen dann auch auf das Geschehen Arbeit
ne? Also Stichwort äh Homeoffice, wie das so schön heißt, auf neudeutsch, auf Corona Deutsch.
Deutsch-Corona, Corona Deutsch.
Na ja, es gibt halt jetzt quasi eine Verpflichtung für Unternehmen, äh Mitarbeitern, Homeoffice anzubieten.
Aber die Freiheit der Mitarbeiter dieses anzunehmen oder nicht.
Ja, also man wird nicht ins Homeoffice geschickt und man dann hat das so zu sein, was sicherlich auch, sagen wir mal, etwas knifflig wäre, das so zu verordnen, weil dann müsste man natürlich quasi.
Abwägen geht das überhaupt und so weiter. Da stecke ich jetzt überhaupt nicht drin, deswegen will ich das auch nicht groß vertiefen. Tatsache ist.
Es ist nicht absehbar, inwiefern jetzt.
Durch Homeoffice Angebote in der Geschäftswelt sich hier nochmal weiter Kontakte reduzieren lassen. Es wäre natürlich zu hoffen, aber das ist äh noch lange nicht sicher. Und was man glaube ich auch nochmal sehen muss.
In der aktuellen Situation, was mir so ein bisschen wenig berichtet wird, Drosten äh betont ist und da hat er ja auch Recht.
Es ist jetzt der einundzwanzigste Januar. Ja, also wir haben jetzt noch zwei Monate Winter.
Also in Berlin fühlt es sich natürlich wieder mal nicht an wie Winter, aber woanders gibt's ja zumindest Schnee. Das mag vielleicht auch helfen. Ich glaube, wenn jetzt hier Schnee lege, dann das würde uns extrem entgegenkommen. Trotzdem ist es halt auch einfach
Grippesaison, es ist einfach die Zeit, wo Infektion am besten arbeiten können. Die Kälte äh all das, die schlecht gelüfteten Räume, das
Das ist halt einfach etwas, was generell Infektionsgeschehen antreibt und bis Ende äh März bleibt das halt im Wesentlichen auch noch so und dann
äh dann hilft auch die Umwelt wieder ein bisschen mit. Hier in irgendeiner Form Infektionsgeschehen äh natürlich einzudämmen.
Wobei eben wenn man wenn man keine Kontakte hat äh spielt dann auch das Wetter keine Rolle. So, aber wie wir sehen, äh finden ja äh gibt es.
Die Leute ja natürlich, das ist, das ist halt so.
OK zwischen dreißig und fünfzig Prozent hm,
Ja, das ist jetzt nicht wirklich Lokdown, also Lokdown, wenn man sich vorstellen, dass ich dann wirklich auf ja dreißig oder zwanzig Prozent oder so runter,
aber äh ja dem ist nicht so und das ist auch wenn man.
Mal auf die Liste der sogenannten ja systemrelevanten Berufe oder wie die das genannt haben guckt.
Ist endlos lang.
Weiß nicht, ob die die auch untergekommen ist, aber äh so äh offenbar ja außer.
Völlig außer Künstlern ist da so ziemlich alles drauf zu finden.
Ja, also ich glaub die ist vier Seiten lang, die Liste der.
Äh der der Berufe klar äh sein Gesundheitsberuf, aber alles was irgendwie im entferntesten dann auch mit
Versorgung zu tun hat, also Wasser, Gas
Elektro aber auch Internet und Telekommunikation, das heißt auch wenn du irgendwie eigentlich als Systemadministrator bist, zum Beispiel auch System.
Relevant. Ähm ja äh zu der Liste der systemrelevanten.
Berufe, genauso, genau Müllabfuhr und äh Transport äh Berufe und alles, was rundum Energieversorgung und äh alles, was irgendwie mit Sicherheit und
Rettung zu tun hat. Klar, aber ja, also äh geht wohl über vier Seiten die Liste und man fragt sich äh wirklich gut, was,
Was ist denn jetzt nicht auf der.
Podcast da vielleicht.
Kommt kommt drauf an, also.
Weiß Podcast, Podcasting ist systemrelevan.
Medienmedienberichterstattung ist glaube ich auch System relevant äh aber äh.
Sehr schön.
Unter bestimmten äh äh Voraussetzungen einen bestimmten Kontexten, aber ja.
Gut, dann gehen wir mal vielleicht so äh paar anderen Meldungen grundsätzlich in Deutschland.
Gibt's ja dann auch äh etwas verspätet diese Diskussion um diese Sequenzierung.
Und äh es gibt jetzt wohl auch die Anweisung äh an Labor, ich weiß gar nicht, haben wir das letzte Mal schon angesprochen? Ich hatte das äh glaube ich in meinen Notizen, aber wir haben's, glaub.
Also es gibt jetzt die Anweisung, dass die Labore.
Auch Sequenzen Sequenzierung vornehmen sollen. Ja, also wir hatten das ja schon mal besprochen. Das findet,
unbedingt so regelmäßig statt. Christian Drossler hat auch gesagt, das wäre jetzt sozusagen auch nicht du, du warst ja relativ schnell dabei, meinst ja Skandalskandal. Er hat es halt anders dargestellt. Er meint so, na ja.
Das macht eigentlich fast kein Land. Es ist halt nur also Deutschland wäre da insofern eben normal und äh es ist nun mal so, dass es in Großbritannien.
Forschungsschwerpunkt war. Wir haben andere Forschungsschwerpunkte, das waren Forschungsschwerpunkte in Großbritannien und man muss auch dazu sagen, dieses auf dieses Entdecken der Variante.
B eins eins sieben Variante ist jetzt nicht unbedingt dadurch erfolgt, dass da so viel sequenziert wird.
Sondern es ist halt diese Besonderheit, dass diese Variante ein spezielles Bild erzeugt hat bei der Durchführung der PCR-Tests.
Die PCR-Tests, sie halt verschiedene Stellen prüfen und diese Variante hat eben quasi da so eine Austastlücke
erzeugt. Also es war dann einfach in dem Berichtsbild erkennbar, dass auf einmal ganz viel positiv zwar gemeldet wurde, aber eben mit einem etwas anderen Muster, als man das normalerweise gesehen hat. Und dadurch ist man eigentlich der Sache erst so richtig auf die Spur geko.
Mit dem äh meins jetzt äh äh Fail ja bei manchen Tests das sozusagen von die halt auf drei verschiedene Proteine getestet haben plötzlich nur noch zwei gefunden haben in größeren Mengen und äh
worüber man dann in der Lage ist, auch ohne Sequenzierung äh zu unterscheiden äh zwischen den Virusvarianten.
Oder zumindest Anhaltspunkte hatte, wo man dann eben mit Sequenzierung das konkret unter äh feststellen kann. Also es
wohl auch Fälle, wo äh diese Austastlücke alleine jetzt nicht unbedingt dafür gesprochen hat, dass es konkret diese eine Variante ist, sondern es irgendwie noch andere Gründe hat, die ich nicht äh erklären kann
Ähm aber so oder so, das war sozusagen das Modell. So äh trotzdem
Wir werden das jetzt sehen, dass mehr sequenziert wird. Die Labor sind entsprechend äh verpflichtet worden und das wird natürlich dann auch vom Staat bezahlt, weil das ist Aufwand und dieser Aufwand wird aber jetzt getrieben werden und dann werden wir sehen, was wir äh
davon haben werden, also ob dadurch zum Beispiel die Sichtbarkeit dieses dieser neuen Variante äh größer wird.
Ja, ich kann.
Tatsächlich da nicht so ganz nachvollziehen, warum Professor Drosten da an der Stelle äh so äh dass das.
Halt mir abtut, sage ich mal, ich meine äh es war von von Anfang
Ich erinnere mich äh noch so im April und Mai, als das losging und die Frage
aufkamen, wie sieht es denn von Mutation aus, war ja auch immer äh so na ja also das ist ein relativ stabiles Virus und da haben wir jetzt erstmal von Mutation nicht so viel zu befürchten
ähm ja wenn man halt nur lange genug wartet, dann.
Wie man jetzt sieht, haben wir sehr wohl von Motationen ein bisschen was zu befürchten und
eigentlich ja ist es vielleicht so ein bisschen auch, will ich nicht sagen Cover JS, aber äh ich,
hörte auch, dass die Mittel, die jetzt für Sequenzierung vorgesehen waren und wie Haushaltsmäßig äh dass die die fürs ganze Jahr vorgesehen haben, waren wie schon im Januar aufgebraucht
das war halt sagen, also wie man's dreht oder wendet, es wird bei uns zu wenig äh sequenziert und ja, mag sein, dass das jetzt in Großbritannien und Forschungs.
Schwerpunkt war
aber wenn man sich jetzt anguckt auch mit den ganzen anderen neuen Virusvarianten, wo es dann auch Meldungen gibt, auch über die brasilianische Variante, dass äh
da wohl Varianten gibt.
Ich will das jetzt nicht so darstellen, dass Drosten gesagt hat, es wäre jetzt nicht hilfreich oder nicht notwendig mehr zu sequenzieren in Bezug auf Corla.
Sondern das war eine Aussage über generelles Infektionsgeschehen, Monitoring.
Unabhängig von Corona, also für Grippe und so weiter.
Mhm. Ja.
Das war seine Aussage.
Hätte das vollkommen ausgereicht, weil man eben normalerweise eben nicht diese pandemischen Zustände hat, wo sie permanent irgendwie das Virus äh äh durcheinander motiert,
sondern da, da funktioniert es halt noch. Jetzt wird's halt anders sein. Wir werden sehen, was dabei rauskommt und dann hoffentlich auch äh nicht so beunruhigende Ergebnisse haben.
Ja, wir können vielleicht festhalten wahrscheinlich die angemessene Situation wäre gewesen äh als sich diese,
Pandemie so weit ausgebreitet hat oder auszubreiten drohte, auch eigentlich die Sequenzierung hochzufahren. So,
glaube ich, kann man, kann man so sagen, da haben wir nicht das
getan, was wahrscheinlich möglich gewesen wäre und was was besser gewesen wäre. Also ich würde sagen, da liegt ein Versäumnis vor, vielleicht kein fatales äh Versäumnis, aber ja äh da waren wir auch nicht.
So gut würde ich sagen jetzt als als Land, äh wie wir hätten sein können oder sein müssen oder sein sollen.
Gut, aber da waren wir jetzt auch nicht schlechter als die anderen Länder und ich glaube, wenn man ist immer so ein bisschen so müßig und einfach zurückzublicken und sagen, ja, da hätten wir viel schlauer sein müssen. Da haben wir uns auch noch über ganz andere äh äh Fragen unterhalten, ne.
Ja ja wir haben sicherlich schwerwiegende und elementare äh Fehler gemacht äh und äh ja Großbritannien äh hat ja jetzt das Sequenzieren in dem Sinne auch nicht
gerettet sind, da waren dann äh.
Andere andere Fehler und und Probleme, die aufgetreten sind, aber ja ich äh also ich finde das Thema Muttertion äh und so äh.
Ist ein beunruhigendes Thema und ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass äh wir ähm ja diese diese Gefahr, die von den Mutationen ausgeht, dass die im Moment
ja, dass da adäquat drauf reagiert wird gerade. So, so auf diese Bedrohung. Mhm.
Lassen wir es dabei. Äh aus der Abteilung
wie nennt man denn diese Abteilung? Gerade wenn man das Gefühl hat, Dinge könnten besser werden, kommt schon wieder die nächste Bedrohung. Es gibt da ein ein neues
äh Paper mit äh Südafrika und wir hatten ja auch schon drüber gesprochen, also diese UK-Virus äh Mutation.
Die äh ebenfalls zeitgleich berichtete Mutation aus Südafrika und auch ein bisschen Brasilien, glaube ich, war auch noch mit dabei
die lagen ja zwar geographisch weit auseinander, aber so virologisch sehr nah beieinander, weil alle diese Mutationen, denen eine höhere Verbreitungsfähigkeit nachgesagt wird, eine spezifische Änderung mit dem Titel
fünfhunderteins Y hatten und das
war ja, sagen wir mal, schon mal Ansicht ein Thema, ja? Die selbe Mutter
in äh Virus stemmen, die geographisch nicht miteinander verbunden sind. Klar, man hat irgendwie Flugreisen und so weiter, aber es ist bei der Nachweisbar, dass diese Mutation unabhängig voneinander entstanden sind.
Jetzt gibt's äh fünf null eins Y Punkt V zwei ein Update.
Und äh da gab's eine äh Studie, die sich diese Mutation angeschaut hat und das ist ähm
Ja, ein bisschen beunruhigend. Also das ist eine Variante, wo eben auch in diesem Spike-Protein des Virus eine ganze Reihe von Mutationen am Start sind,
Und die haben die dann mal gleich getestet, wie man das so macht äh gegen äh monoklonale Antikörper, also das ist sozusagen.
Spezifische Antikörper ein einziger Typ der eben auf was Besonderes anspricht in diesem Spike-Protein und aber auch im Vergleich dazu ähm
Antikörper aus Blutseren, also tatsächlich jetzt von Leuten, die sich eben mit dem Virus schon mal infiziert haben, da nimmt man Blut und dann äh kann man halt so ein Blutserum daraus extrahieren, indem dann eben auch so eine Antikörper äh Brühe rum äh schwimmt, also dass es dann
polyglonal. Man lernt,
und stellt sich raus, dass ungefähr bei der Hälfte dieser Seren äh diese neue Virus äh Variante eine abgeschwächte Wirkung zeigt. Also das sozusagen die,
Natürlich aufgebaute Immunität gegen diese neue Virusvariante nicht mehr so gut funktioniert.
Ja? Das klingt jetzt erstmal nicht gut, weil das letzte, was wir hören wollen ist
dass wir jetzt ein ein neue Virus Variante haben, die sich toll verbreiten kann und die gegebenenfalls die ganze Impfarbeit vollkommen zunichte macht.
Dass von uns seit äh ja von mir seit einigen Wochen äh äh beschworene ähm Worst Case Szenario, dass wir im Sommer, wenn wir dann durch sind äh mit äh Impfen.
Gegen ja Kovit neunzehn, äh dass wir dann Kowit einundzwanzig äh kriegen und.
Äh das Update kurvet einundzwanzig und wird dann nochmal von vorne anfangen müssen. Gut.
Mit dem dass ja und
Deswegen äh halt um die Wahrscheinlichkeit äh einfach zu minimieren, ist es jetzt auch super wichtig, die Zahlen im
im Griff zu halten und klein zu halten und jede Variante von dem Virus äh zu reduzieren, um äh immer nur betonen
Logdowns funktionieren gegen jede Variante dieses Virus, aber halt unterschiedlich gut, aber sie funktioniert.
Das kann man jetzt auch in engen äh äh mal kurz den den internationalen Ausblick ganz ganz kurz sehen. Sieht man jetzt auch, dass auch England und äh Irland es geschafft haben, trotz
der neuen infektiösen Variante auch mit Loggo und die Zahlen runterzukriegen. Also es ist jetzt nicht
nicht völlig aussichtslos. So, ja, weil wir sind ja nicht völlig hilflos. Äh den neuen Varianten gegenüber, aber äh wir dürfen sie auch nicht ignorieren.
Genau, bevor jetzt Leute totalen Herzkasper äh kriegen, weil UKW berichtete äh jetzt kommt hier irgendwie die Virus Apokalypse Teil zwei. Äh ganz so schlimm ist es jetzt nicht. Also, nur weil jetzt die Hälfte der Seren hier eine abgeschwächte Wirkung zeigt
bedeutet das nicht, dass eine äh vorhandene Immunität
im Körper nicht in der Lage ist, auch diese neue Variante zu bekämpfen, weil das, was im Blutserum sich an Antikörpern befindet,
spielt zwar eine Rolle, aber das ist beim Immunsystem nicht die vollständige Wahrheit
da gibt's noch ganz andere Faktoren und äh der Körper ist in der Lage äh so einiges aufzufahren, sodass das eben nicht automatisch bedeutet, dass äh eine vorhandene Immunität nicht wirkt. Und darüber hinaus.
Die Immunität, die diese Impfung hervorruft. Speziell, die eben mit diesen MRNA-Wirkstoffen.
Die erzeugt ja eine noch viel stärkere Abwehrreaktion des Körpers als eine normale Infektion. Allein schon weil wir eben zweimal
geimpft werden. Die erste Dose ist schon ein ziemlicher Klopper.
Geht's richtig rund. Der Körper regt sich total auf und sagt, was ist denn hier los und äh fährt alles hoch und dann gibt's drei Wochen oder vier Wochen später gleich nochmal eine Dosis und dann wird das Ganze eben
nochmal so richtig auf die Palme gebracht und dann äh äh wird halt richtig zugemacht. Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen so, wenn sie bei dir einbrechen, ne
Ja, ja, dann dann findest du das erstmal scheiße und dann dann bist du auch erstmal eine Weile aufmerksam und drei Wochen später na ja, hast du das dann auch eigentlich schon wieder verdrängt. Hast zwar irgendwelche Maßnahmen ergriffen, aber vielleicht nicht genug, dann brechen sie nochmal bei dir ein.
Und dann werden aber auch neue Schlösser gekauft und dann wird wirklich nochmal äh doppelt dicht gemacht und das ganze Security
Konzept wirklich überdacht, Datenverlust, Backups und so weiter, immer wieder dieselbe Geschichte. Man muss erst zweimal richtig in die Scheiße treten, bevor sich was bessert
Und so ein bisschen ist es halt auch glaube ich hier bei dieser äh Immunitätsantwort.
Ja, also kann auf jeden Fall festhalten, dass äh die Immunität, die man durch Impfen gewinnt irgendwie breiter und länger und stärker äh wirkt in der Regel als die, die man durch.
Die Infektion äh äh gewinnt. Aber äh so die die,
was auf jeden Fall äh die die Studie, worauf die hindeutet ist, dass man potentiell ein paar mehr Fälle von Reinfektionen
sehen wird als bisher. Hat's ja bisher immer gegeben. Das war ja auch von Anfang an,
Oh, da hat sich jemand, äh, der äh zum zweiten Mal infiziert, äh der.
Ja jemand infiziert, der schon mal Kovet hatte und das kommt immer wieder mal vor und ähm aber es waren halt relativ kleine
zahlen. Also es war jetzt nicht viele Leute und ja ähm also insofern auch hier.
Jetzt äh kein Grund zur Hoffnungslosigkeit, aber äh auf jeden Fall Wachsamkeit ist.
Genau. Dann schauen wir doch mal, wie es eigentlich mit den Impfungen so läuft
Vielleicht eine Sache vorweg. Die Bundesregierung hat jetzt auch ein eigenes Dashboard nur für den Fortschritt der Impfung gebracht unter Impf-Dashboard,
DE diese ganze Pandimidi bringt uns auch wirklich die merkwürdigsten neuen Wort-und Getümer, aber so heißt es nun mal
ist eine äh ganz hübsch gestaltete äh Seite, die den aktuellen Stand äh recht
plastisch rüberbringt, also um schnell mal sich was zu äh äh klicken, ganz gut. Da wird dann in einem Satz zusammengefasst, was eigentlich so Phase ist. Hier steht dann halt einfach aktueller Impfstatus. Am einundzwanzigsten.
Januar zwanzig einundzwanzig wurden in Deutschland sechsundachtzigtausendfünfhundertsechzehn Impfungen durchgeführt.
Damit haben nun eine Million dreihundertsechsundachtzigtausendvierhundertvierundsechzig Personen, eins Komma sieben Prozent der Gesamtbevölkerung. Eine Erstimpfung erhalten und hundertfünfzehntausend Personen bereits die Zweitimpfung.
Schön zusammengefasst und äh noch ein Vergleich äh wie schnell das denn jetzt geht. Also derzeit wäre das jetzt der normale äh Tagesschnitt, dann hätten wir äh jede Sekunde eine Impfung
Na ja, ist aber, glaube ich, nicht der Tagesschnitt, sondern da sieht's noch nicht so richtig gut aus. Also tatsächlich.
Finde ich den Zuwachs bei dem Impfen,
immer noch zu mager, also das finde ich glaube ich nicht nur das ist im Wesentlichen eigentlich dasselbe wie letzte Woche äh auch.
Das ist einfach ein linearer Anstieg, das heißt der R ist eins so.
Nimmt einfach immer nur um dieselbe Zahl wieder zu. Da ist keine Dynamik drin und die müssen wir natürlich reinkriegen. Das heißt, die Probleme mit Versorgung, Slash äh Logistik,
Verimpfung, Terminvergabe, was auch immer im Einzelnen der Grund ist, dass da ist der geordische Knoten noch nicht durchgeschnitten worden.
Ja. Nee, definitiv nicht. Es schwankt halt so im Moment zwischen ja, sagen wir mal vierzig und hundertfünftausend Dosen am Tag gerade.
Sehr. Ja und.
Dann dauert's noch Jahre, wenn wir wenn das so weitergeht. Also das muss sich deutlich steigern.
Also fünfundsiebzigtausend.
Pro Tag ist der sieben Tagesschnitt jetzt bei Impfungen in Deutschland und.
Ja USA ist glaube ich ungefähr zehn Mal so viel, weil beiden hat ja jetzt.
Sagen äh hundert Millionen Leute in den ersten hundert Tagen seiner Präsidentschaft will er impfen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar ein erreichbares Ziel, weil die USA sowieso schon bei, wie gesagt, achthundert, neunhunderttausend, glaube ich, pro Tag sind.
Und ja also die schaffen im Moment doppelt so viel pro Tag wie wir, kann man äh.
Sagen, ja.
Also im Verhältnis zur Bevölkerung.
Bevölkerung, ja, glaube ich.
Ich vergleich mal kurz, es ist in etwa null null neun null nee dreimal so viel.
Dreimal so viel sogar. Ja. Mhm.
Ja und äh schafft ähm ungefähr fünf Mal so viel.
Und Israel ist äh weit ab von allen und schafft noch sehr viel mehr so viel. Also ich glaube der Faktor liegt so bei.
Zwölf oder so ähm das ist schon äh krass. Also da werden pro Tag eins Komma acht Prozent geimpft. Also das, was wir jetzt insgesamt haben, das macht Israel gerade pro Tag.
Genau, schauen wir doch mal auf die Situation in Israel, da da wird's ja jetzt demnächst spannend, also Stand heute sind achtunddreißig Prozent der Bevölkerung geimpft, das ist schon mal eine ziemlich beeindruckende Zahl.
Also erst erst, sie haben ihre Erstdosis bekommen oder.
Äh ja.
Genau, also achtunddreißig Prozent hat äh eine Erstdosis bekommen. Ähm bei der Altersgruppe siebzig Plus, also.
Nicht nur siebzig bis achtzig, sondern also alle über siebzigjährigen. Da haben.
Also siebzig achtzig und neunzig die Gruppen sind relativ gleich beieinander, deswegen habe ich das jetzt mal zur Vereinfachung zusammengefasst. Also siebzigjährige und älter in Israel, davon haben achtzig Prozent die erste Impfung bekommen, dreißig Prozent, die zweite Impfung.
Und wie gesagt, jeden Tag eins Komma acht Prozent der Bevölkerung dazu. Also es es geht richtig ratze, ratze, fatze und sie steigern sich sogar noch. Derzeit, also es kann sein, dass sie demnächst oft oft auf zwei Prozent hochgehen
das bedeutet wiederum, man sollte jetzt bald die Auswirkungen sehen. Das haben wir ja letzte Woche im Prinzip schon mal.
Angesprochen, dass da sich jetzt bald mal was tun müsste, denn das Infektionsgeschehen und auch die Sterbezahlen sind
nach wie vor extrem hoch in Israel. Also da ist es viel, viel schlimmer als bei uns.
Äh gut das trägt, obwohl dazu bei, dass wir eben jetzt auch diese ganze Impfohrreise richtig durchziehen. Ich gehe mal davon aus, nächste Woche wissen wir da schon mehr.
Und äh allerspätestens in zwei Wochen sollte sich eigentlich was tun.
Ja, ja, gut, werden jetzt sehen.
An dem Beispiel äh tatsächlich ab wann sich.
Ja Herdenimunität in den Zahlen bemerkbar macht und ich glaube, das wird noch äh eine Weile länger.
Da ist das äh so richtig Impact auf die Zahlen hat, aber wir werden sehen. Es soll auf jeden Fall spannend.
Na gut, ich meine, wenn jetzt sind dreißig Prozent geimpft. So, in zwei Wochen sind diese, sollte bei diesen dreißig Prozent alleine schon äh eine vollständige Immunität erreicht sein durch die Impfstoffe.
Das ist das, was ich sage. So und wenn dreißig Prozent der am stärksten Betroffenen Gruppe.
Rausfällt quasi für schwere Verläufe, dann müsse sich das zeigen.
Also definitiv ja an den Todeszahlen und äh müsste sich halt auch äh in den Alters in bestimmten Altersgruppen dann tatsächlich bemerkbar machen. Also wenn die da bei achtzig, da gebe ich dir vollkommen Recht
dass wir es vielleicht noch nicht so sehr in der Gesamtbevölkerung, aber bei äh den ja, bei den über siebzigjährigen müssten wir tatsächlich dann demnächst was sehen.
Genau, also wenn es sich nicht sofort in den Sterbezahlen zeigt, weil die sich ja auch noch weiter nach hinten verschieben, wird es sich in Krankenhauseinlieferungen äh zeigen und Behandlungen und Beatmung und all diesen ganzen.
Äh äh Behandlungsparameter sage ich mal.
Gut. Jetzt sind wir eigentlich schon äh am Ende. Ich habe noch einen Tipp für euch.
Und zwar äh kommen wir jetzt hier wie angekündigt nochmal auf diese Masken äh Geschichte zurück. Es gibt eine schöne Ressource der äh Fachhochschule Münster,
Eine Seite, die sich mit dem Thema Wiederverwendung von FFB zwei Masken auseinandergesetzt hat und wo auf einer Seite schön zusammengefasst ist
Wie es denn äh eigentlich so ist mit diesen Masten und was man vor allem tun kann, um sie wieder zu verwenden und unter welchen Bedingungen man sie wieder verwenden sollte.
Es ist halt generell glaube ich eine gute Idee sich diese Masken zu besorgen. Wie gesagt, die könnt ihr auf Amazon einfach bestellen und sind zu teuer auch nicht, ne? Eins fünfzig ist der Preis, den ich jetzt äh jüngst erzielt habe. Jo Milage May very
Vielleicht kriege ich das billiger, vielleicht auch ein bisschen teurer, aber im Prinzip äh geht das. Jetzt werden vielleicht manche sagen, wow, zwei Euro pro Maske und so weiter. Ist ja teuer,
Na ja gut
schauen wir mal, wie lange die sich halten. Also auf dieser Webseite ist das alles schön zusammengefasst. Ich greife mal so die wichtigsten Punkte meiner Meinung nach auf. Also zunächst einmal eine Wiederverwendbarkeit ist möglich. Grundsätzlich heißt es ja, man sollte die Dinger nach dem Tag nicht mehr benutzen,
ja? Klar, also die sind jetzt normalerweise für Dauergebrauch, sagt man auch so nach einer Stunde oder so muss er abnehmen, also im Krankenhaus sind das nochmal ganz andere Parameter, aber wir reden ja jetzt eher davon, wenn ihr mal rausgeht,
Ja, Supermarkt und so weiter, keine Ahnung, vielleicht eben auch einfach auf offener Straße aus äh Vorsichtsmaßnahmen heraus, also sagen wir mal, ihr benutzt die so über den Tag
hinweg. Dann landet natürlich da also im Idealfall kein Virus drin, aber kann ja sein, dass einen die Maske eben auch mal wirklich konkret
geschützt hat. Also kann man davon ausgehen, dass äh unter Umständen auch äh Virus da drin ist, aber da landet natürlich auch der ganze andere Schleim, den man da eben so normalerweise ausspuckt. Auch noch mit drin und man will das ja irgendwie dann auch äh weghaben, möchte sich auch sicher sein, dass wenn man so eine Maske wiederverwendet, dass sie dann irgendwie auch.
Okay ein Zustand ist ein nicht irgendwie groß infiziert und ja im Prinzip auch immer noch dasselbe leistet wie am ersten Tag. Grundsätzlich sollte man diese Masken.
Maximal fünfmal benutzen, also fünf Tage benutzen.
Wenn ihr jetzt einen dicken Stapel von Masken kauft, gibt's so zwanziger Pakete für dreißig Euro äh so ähm.
Dann ist es glaube ich eine gute Idee, ihr macht euch so eine.
Ja, so ein, so ein, so ein Aufhängeboard irgendwie Haken an der Wand oder Wäscheleine oder so und äh benutzt einfach sieben.
Masten über die Woche und,
für jeden Wochentag habt ihr quasi so ein ein Aufhängepunkt, das heißt du hast eine Montagsmaske, die benutzt du am Montag und danach hängst du sie an dem Montaghagen und am Dienstag nimmst du Dienstag und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn nämlich so eine
Maske, sieben Tage bei Raumluft trocknet, dann ist die nach Aussage der FH Münster auf dieser Webseite
also dann ist da einfach durch die Raumluft allein, durch dieses Trockenen äh in der Wohnung ist äh alles weg, was äh da nicht hingehört.
Wenn man kurzfristiger Masken wieder ähm benutzbar machen möchte, gibt's noch eine zweite Möglichkeit.
Nämlich die bei exakt achtzig Grad zu trocknen. Da ist es wohl relativ wichtig, dass man diese achtzig Grad auch genau trifft. Also,
Ein Grad mehr, ein Grad weniger macht's jetzt nicht so aus, aber schon bei siebzig Grad ist es was anderes als äh
als bei achtzig und ähm so ab neunzig Grad wird's dann auch ein bisschen schwierig für die Materialien
Also man sollte zusehen, dass man einen Ofen hat, der entweder gutes Temperatur, also ein gut funktionierendes Thermometer drin hat oder man benutzt so einen braten Thermometer, dass man irgendwie ja vielleicht auch äh äh greifbar hat oder so ein spezielles Ofenthermometer, sowas kann man auch kurven
Und wenn man da die Maske sechzig Minuten reintut, dann funktioniert das irgendwie auch.
Ja, man sollte halt Masken nicht teilen, ist klar und und das sind so die beiden empfohlenen Methoden. Könnt ihr alles auf dieser Webseite nachlesen, da steht auch warum andere Methoden keine gute Idee sind, also so Waschmaschine oder Spülmaschine äh oder im Kochtopf mit Wasserdampf und so alles ganz schlechte Ideen, weil dabei einfach das Material
beschädigt wird, beziehungsweise eine viel zu starke mechanische Belastung auf die Maske gelegt wird und dann ist die einfach nicht mehr so wie vorher. Wo man ja vielleicht auch denken könnte, dass das eine tolle Idee ist, ist so Mikrowelle.
Ja.
Das Problem ist halt nur, Mikrowelle basiert eben äh auf der Technik, dass eben durch die Mikrowellenstrahlung Wasser äh erhitzt wird und wenn da kein Wasser drin ist, ja, dann dann wird da halt auch nicht groß was entfernt, also die Mikrowelle allein tötet jetzt keine Viren
Äh
Das tut zwar UV-Licht, aber auch so äh Masken und der UV-Lampen legen, ist auch keine gute Idee, denn das würden nur gegen Viren äh helfen, die jetzt wirklich
unmittelbar auf der Oberfläche sind, aber alles was so tiefer ins Fließ eingedrungen ist, das äh funktioniert nicht und UV-Licht ist halt auch nicht gut für etwaiche Kunststoffe, die da noch mit drin sind. Also, ich würde einfach mal sagen
diese sieben Tage Wäsche leidet, das ist wahrscheinlich die beste Idee oder irgendwelche Haken und dann,
damit prima arbeiten, habt immer eine frische Maske und dann halten die eben dann auch,
sehr lange, also wenn ihr wirklich jeden Tag damit rausgeht und jeden Tag das benutzt, dann habt ihr quasi mit so sieben Masken pro Person, könnt ihr irgendwie fünf Wochen durchhalten.
Und ähm wenn man sie nicht so oft benutzt auch häufiger.
Ja, zum Trocknen äh
Ofens äh ja habe ich noch so ein paar Anekdoten beziehungsweise Erfahrungen äh so.
Ja, also erstens, wenn ich noch ergänzen wollen, also Gasherd ist jetzt nicht so die super Idee, ich hab,
alt manchmal Ofen benutzt, wenn wir irgendwelche elektrischen.
Elektronischen Geräte dann äh ins Wasser gefallen sind äh oder so. Und ich habe dann.
Einmal hatte ich eine Fernbedienung, weiß ich noch, die habe ich dann versucht allerdings im Gasherd auf niedrigster Stufe zu trocknen, da hatte ich dann hinterher so schön
überbackene Fernbedienung, die ist dann so richtig schön geschmolzen und äh
Also jetzt nichts zu tropfen, sondern wurde halt so weich wie Käse.
Ja, also deswegen äh äh Gasherd, also definitiv keine keine gute Idee, aber äh Elektroherd,
geht es übrigens auch ein ganz guter Tipp, äh falls man ähm ja so zum Beispiel gängige Apple, äh, die weiß ist, iPads oder Telefone
so repariert, dann da ist ja immer dieser oder generell Sachen, die mit Hitzeempfindlichen Kleber
verklebt sind, wo man dann üblicherweise mit der Heißluftpistole oder so rangeht, nicht festgestellt, ist der viel bessere Weg
und auch präzisere äh Weg tatsächlich das auch so wie hier im Backofen zu machen und das ganze Gerät dann zu erhitzen äh.
Welche Temperatur.
Ja äh auf äh je nachdem auch so, weiß ich nicht, achtzig, neunzig Grad ungefähr äh ja, ja. Mhm.
Das können die äh also das können die alles ab so und dann es geht also viel besser als mit jetzt mit der mit der Heißluft äh Pistole, weil mit der Eisluftpistole machst du's halt an einem Ende warm und am anderen ist es dir dann wieder äh äh abgekühlt und so, also
dagegen.
Viertelstunde, zwanzig Minuten so bei je nachdem siebzig, achtzig Grad im im Ofen kriegt man halt äh geklebte,
Displays oder oder Gläser dann wunderbar abgezogen.
Ihr seht schon, bei UKW gibt's Tipps für alle Lebenslagen von Pandemie Abwehr bis äh iPhone Reparatur, alles drin.
Ja, Pabel, heute haben wir ein nicht so dickes Programm, da würde ich sagen, machen wir mal eine kürzere Sendung äh draus. Ich denke.
Äh das ist auch mal ganz gut. Wie gesagt, wenn ihr Lust habt und Gelegenheit habt, da für unser Clubhausgespräch, dann kommt doch da dazu, wenn nicht, dann seid ihr natürlich weiterhin eingeladen
euren Senf uns per Kommentar im Blog
äh zuzuwerfen oder ihr könnt's also auch auf Twitter anschreiben, ME Unterstrich UKW ist der Twitter-Account für diese Sendung
Oder wenn ihr alles von der Mieterebene hören würdet, dann gibt's auch at Meterebene, ihr könnt mir folgen, äh Tim Prittler oder Dir at Pavel Meier und äh ihr könnt das aber auch alles nicht machen und einfach nächste Woche wieder reinhören und äh
schon ob sie, ob ihr wieder raus dürft aus dem Schrank.
Ja, er.
So sieht's aus.
Ganz gut zusammengefasst, würde ich sagen. Ähm vielleicht positiver Ausblick äh im Moment. Äh also unser Ausharren äh zu Hause im Moment zeigt.
Glücklicherweise gerade Wirkung und äh hoffen wir, äh dass wir das äh alle äh noch lange genug durchhalten. Äh.
Ja und und das nicht und die Erfolge, die wir jetzt gerade äh äh erzielen, nicht wieder rechtfertigt verspielen.
Genau, das wird schon. Ich bleibe optimistisch. Also Leute, Kopf hoch, weitermachen und wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis bald.
Yo, tschüs.